how the hell do you know we you know how  they say we have an economic expansion  of 128 months no we haven't we we've had  an economic expansion of nearly 150  months 140 months take cove it out  if you took covet out and they kept  rates at zero or half a points federal  reserve this economic expansion would  have continued past february of 2020  right so what happens when the econom  economy is growing how do you know who's  a real millionaire mm-hmm like how do  you because so many people are leveraged  yeah how do you know you don't know how  do you know who's the real comedian how  do you know who's the real there's a  filtering process that we all got to go  through right that's right okay  so the only way you know the filtering  process is during bath seasons that is  the only way you're gonna know who's  real and who's not